what's up gq we're the city girls and
today we're going undercover on the
internet
it's actually me
[Music]
okay
ready
you like people calling you your
government name right now no i i don't
like that i actually hate it i don't
like people coming by my first name who
don't know me i don't really have a
problem but no don't call me my real
name
next
who y'all think has the best sounds on
tick tock i'm going with the city girls
i do like some of the other tick tocks
that i'll be hearing like
i think tick tock is just fun but i do
think gabe city girls had the best sound
tick-tock
[Music]
where is the nikki collab we're hoping
for it in the future
seriously and a lot of people like try
to make fun of me like you're never
going to get your future but you never
know what could happen
post it
i need the skin routine man come on now
that was like a filter you couldn't even
see me
that was gray as hell and i think i um
had makeup residue still left on my face
honestly truly i remember the skin
routine is just soap and water just wash
your face basically because i got
sensitive skin if sometimes i use people
products and it don't go good for me at
all
it's the ground
y'all engaged
no i'm not engaged
yet
you may not believe it but it's actually
us
twitter
wait our city girl stands called the
citizens laughing my ass off why do i
love it jt made it up so that's a
question for her i call him the citizens
because you know like people who live in
the city or around like citizens like i
just called on the citizens because i
didn't know what else to call them i
started calling them besties but then
everybody else started using it and it
just became like too confusing so i just
call it citizens city girl citizens city
boys citizens whatever
i mean you can read that question i
don't want to read it with attitude this
will say why did the city girls make all
their fuss about clearing circulated
just not to come out with a video we
actually do have a video so that's not
true we do got a video for speculating
you loud and wrong
monique
cora
who are the five hottest female rappers
in the industry ranked one through five
one being the best i'm not going to
answer that question because i ain't
nobody to be telling nobody who did it
best or who the worst i would just say
city girls are one through five
how old is rapper yo miami i'm 27. how
many kids does yeah miami have i have
two kids i have one boy and one girl
youtube
drake in my feelings why didn't he give
credit to the city girls since they sang
thank you drake we appreciate you
don't listen to the people i guess it
was actually sampled in the song along
with a lot of other people i think lil
wayne was also sampling that song big
friday was also sampled in that song
with a lot of different people but that
was still a big big moment and a big
leap by career a huge step and we
appreciate it
money bag yo said some remix featuring
the city girls i want more city girls on
these collabs with grapes like money bag
yo two chains gucci mane meek mill etc
etc i agree i rap better like that i
don't make fun music good to me i really
rap bet on traffic
back to twitter obviously not saying
nobody else but you and somebody said is
that about maggie that's actually a
summer walker song yeah i was listening
to that song so i just tweeted the
lyrics it wasn't about nobody i was just
feeling the lyrics at the time i was
listening to summer walker and i just
tweeted it
jt and every picture you post i see a
new tattoo how many do you have i don't
even have i don't know have this this
and this
just three tattoos i don't have tattoos
like that
while the city girls didn't bring the
girl who made the tick tock tins on
stage with them bet awards we actually
got home youtube with us if y'all go
look it up it's us and layla
saying right now 1 30 am thoughts anyone
what helps you write your routes when
you're trying to write it depends on
like what type of movie like if we're
going for a more talking [ __ ]
i feel like
i don't know i want to expect you
we need a uzi and jc collab
one day
wikipedia
before wrapping your miami was an
instagram influencer who promoted her
own fashion line i ran an instagram page
that was called karisha's closet and i
used to sell like bandage wear like
dresses for the club and then i started
selling like little two pieces and
bathing suits so yes this is true
enough questions for now we getting off
the internet
[Music]